today on the matt well show outrage over
a plan by some congressional republicans
to form a caucus dedicated to preserving
our anglo-saxon political traditions
this is offensive because as the new
rules clearly state anything even
loosely associated with whiteness is bad
we'll talk about and break that rule
today also five headlines including a
high-profile elected democrat committing
jury tampering and incitement shockingly
the people who were so worried about
incitement a few months ago have nothing
to say about this and the mother of a
trans boy goes viral but the video
proves the opposite of the point it's
supposed to prove in our daily
cancellation we'll talk about the
millions of americans who apparently
will cling on to their masks even after
they're vaccinated because for them it's
become nothing more than a security
blanket we'll talk about that and much
more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
before we get going today i want to
mention that i'll be speaking at ut
austin on thursday if i have a voice by
then the title of my talk uh is
delusions of gender how the left turns
boys into girls
and this again is a talk i'm giving in
austin
i expect a warm reception hopefully not
in a literal sense so you can go to my
twitter facebook page and find a link to
register to attend that talk there now
if you made the mistake of spending any
time on the internet over the weekend
you may have become acquainted with the
latest fake controversy i'll read now
from the nbc news article on friday
get ready to be confused about what
you're supposed to be offended by
exactly but here it is
it says a group of ultra conservative
house republicans including
representative marjorie taylor green
are discussing launching an america
first caucus that would protect quote
anglo-saxon political traditions
representative louis gomer of texas told
reporters that he's looking at joining
there's an america first caucus he said
confirming that green is involved a
seven-page organizing document that
includes the group's name and a logo
first reported by punchbowl news
whatever that is
says america is a nation with a border
and a culture strengthened by a common
respect for uniquely anglo-saxon
political traditions
it adds that societal trust and
political unity are threatened when
foreign citizens are imported in mass
into a country especially with
institutional support for assimilation
without institutional support for
assimilation and an expansive welsh
welfare state to bail them out should
they fail to contribute positively to
the country
okay
that's it's a four-page document but
that's part of what it says
now if you have a fully intact brain
which has not been partially eaten by
worms at this point you'll hear that and
think okay so what
yes america first conservatives are
against mass immigration
no no news there and that's for a good
reason they're against it by the way
yes we're supposed to be a nation with a
border and a culture
and yes we have anglo-saxon political
traditions all of that is undeniably
true
but it's that last part right
anglo-saxon which sent the outrage into
overdrive
the outrage followed as it always does
the familiar path first leftists on the
internet were mad and then high-profile
democrats joined in and then
high-profile republicans in an effort to
signal that their really good little
boys and girls also joined
representative adam kissinger of um
illinois said that the representatives
involved in the caucus should be
punished
and they should have all their committee
assignments taken away representative
ken buck said that the caucus plan was
hateful and ignorant
representative liz cheney of wyoming
called it nativist racist and somehow
anti-semitic i don't know and house
minority leader kevin mccarthy called it
a nativist dog whistle
and then the democrats came over came
over and patted them all on their heads
and gave them lollipops i guess because
that's what they were hoping for finally
the inevitable conclusion to this
familiar saga as nbc news again reports
uh now this was uh yesterday they said
two far-right house republicans linked
to a document calling for the protection
of anglo-saxon political traditions
distanced themselves from what they said
was a draft
of prescriptions for an america first
caucus representative paul gosar said in
a saturday statement that he did not
author the document and that he became
aware of it only after it was reported
by the news media saying he'll continue
to work on america first issues in the
house freedom caucus
he said quote let me be perfectly clear
i did not author this paper in fact i
first became aware of it by reading
about it in the news yesterday like
everybody else
in addition nick dyer a spokesperson for
representative marjorie taylor green
said in a statement that the document
was merely an early planning proposal
and nothing was agreed to or approved
all right now it's unfortunate that they
distance themselves as there is nothing
that
needs to be distanced from
narrowing in on the anglo-saxon term
it is again undeniably true that we have
anglo-saxon political traditions
anyone who favors our system of
government must also be in favor of
preserving those traditions
the critics can't really deny this and
for the most part they don't or aren't
bothering to deny it instead they're
simply insisting that we can't
acknowledge this truth and if we do
acknowledge it we can't be proud of it
that's the rule
and it is a rule strictly followed by
the [ __ ] contingent on the right
of which of which kevin mccarthy is is
the leader
the rest of us though should just ignore
it
what's the problem with anglo-saxon
exactly
well simply that it's loosely associated
with whiteness
in the minds of the left it doesn't mean
the same thing there are plenty of white
people who aren't anglo-saxon plenty of
people who defend and enjoy anglo-saxon
traditions who are not white
and would have been by the way invited
into that caucus
but even so anything associated however
loosely with the ever broadening
category known as whiteness
cannot be anything but evil that's the
rule now
notice how the america first caucus
never said that only those with
anglo-saxon ancestry can join the caucus
no see for that kind of racism you have
to look to the congressional black
caucus which excludes white members in
fact here's a political article from
2007 and i think it seems relevant here
it says quote as a white liberal running
in a majority african-american district
tennessee democrat stephen cohen made a
novel pledge on the campaign trail last
year if elected he would seek to become
the first white member of the
congressional black caucus now these are
freshmen in congress cohen has changed
his plans he said he has dropped his bid
after several current and former caucus
members made it clear to him that whites
need not apply
cohen said i think they're real happy
i'm not going to join
um
it's their caucus and they do things
their way you don't force your way in
you need to be invited cohen said that
he became convinced that joining the
caucus would be a social faux pas after
seeing news reports that former
representative william lacy clay a
co-founder of the caucus had circulated
a memo telling members it was quote
critical that the group remained quote
exclusively african-american
okay there you have a congressional
caucus
which denies entry based on race
and yet we're supposed to accept that a
caucus which denies entry to whites is
not racist while a caucus that merely
mentions anglo-saxon traditions is
racist
if you're still going along with these
kinds of double standards and accepting
them i don't know what to tell you
you're a lost cause
but i think i might sell the issue short
by calling it a mere double standard
double standards are annoying right
the double standards around race though
in this country are far worse than mere
annoyances
again the problem with the term
anglo-saxon in the minds of those
offended by it
is that they associate it with whiteness
and whiteness as they've made quite
clear is bad
the message is that if you're white the
only thing you're allowed to feel about
your identity is guilt everybody else on
earth all other races
may feel
proud of their identity in history
they may even feel superior
and declare themselves to be so publicly
that is outright definitional racism and
it's acceptable as long as the person
displaying it is not white
for whites the only acceptable feeling
is one of guilt remorse and regret all
for sins they didn't personally commit
and which even if their ancestors did
commit everyone else's ancestors also
committed
but all of the sins of the past slavery
racism conquest which are shared by all
people
the common heritage of the whole fallen
human race
must be carried exclusively by white
people
to even protest this or object to it is
racist
to even say so much as i'm a white man
and i like being who i am
is racist you're not allowed to like
being who you are
if you're white
this is not defensible it's not
sustainable either
history shows
clearly the danger of singling out
certain races and saying oh yeah well
we're allowed to say certain things and
do certain things and have certain
attitudes but not you you can't this is
for us not
you that has never worked out well
though in another sense it's
had it has exactly the effect that it
that is intended
so it works out perfectly in another
sense the point is to divide and
dehumanize
that's what's happening now
and if you're white all you're supposed
to do in response to all of that is keep
apologizing
which is why i must say as a white man i
for one
do not apologize for being who i am i
don't accept any historical racial guilt
at all
i apologize for nothing
i don't expect anyone else to either
what i want is for us all to simply live
under the same standard
that's it
and that should not be controversial
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know i've been telling you all about
constitution coach for uh for weeks now
and really pay attention because this is
your last week to get signed up for
their april 25th class
at
constitutioncoach.com that's your last
chance this week my friends over at
constitutioncoach.com have many
wonderful programs for equipping
citizens to defend liberty by studying
and living out the constitution um and
you want to experience this for yourself
i've experienced their constitutional
defense course and the great thing is
that you cover all the bases it's the
intellectual bases you're learning about
our history about the constitution
you're also getting the physical
training at um the premier firearms
training facility in the nation all in
the same course you get to join hundreds
of other patriots from across the nation
for a time of learning training and
fellowship with like-minded people
whether you've shot guns your whole life
or you've never touched one or you're
somewhere in between in your skill level
they took me to a whole new skill level
they'll do the same for anyone
and that's why you need to not just get
a gun but learn how to carry with
confidence and get the training you need
to defend yourself and your family go to
constitutioncoach.com rick and the
constitution coach team have another
class again on april 25th but it's
filling up fast so
last chance go visit
constitutioncoach.com
all right so
as
mentioned
uh
in the opening maxine waters
perhaps the biggest scumbag in congress
i mean there's a lot of competition for
that title but i i would maybe give her
i would you know she she's in the the
top three certainly she's in the wrong
um anyway she traveled to minnesota
she traveled from dc to minnesota to
incite a riot and intimidate jurors
that's what she did
a whole series of felonies she committed
and she did it on video for everyone to
see we can all watch it we'll watch it
right now here it is
and so
yes i would like to see the bill in
congress pass on police reform but i
know that the right wing the racist are
opposed to it and i don't know what's
going to happen to it but i know this
we've got to stay in the street and
we've got to we've got to demand justice
as a black man despite all of the
efforts
i feel like nothing changes and george
floyd is waking so many people up
yet nothing has happened just but you
know despite the rhetoric like what what
needs to happen that's different this
year
than all the years we are looking for a
guilty verdict i am very hopeful
and i hope
that we're going to get
a verdict that can say guilty guilty
guilty and if we don't
we cannot go away and not just
manslaughter right i mean oh no not
manchester united no no no this is this
is guilty for murder i don't know
whether it's in the first degree but as
far as i'm concerned is first degree
what happens if we do not
get what you just told what should the
people do what's your protesters on the
street
i didn't hear you what happens what
should protesters do
well we gotta stay on the street uh and
we've got to get more active we've got
to get more confrontational we've got to
make sure that they they know that we
need business
more confrontational
can you get more confrontational and
burning buildings down well we're going
to find out
by the way she's calling for
chauvin to be found guilty of a charge
that he's not
charged with he's not charged with
premeditated murder he's not charged
with first-degree murder
um
that's what she wants so she's already
setting it up
and doing so intentionally of course
that no matter what i mean he could be
found guilty on every single charge
and that's not going to be enough
because he's not he wasn't charged with
enough crimes as far as she's concerned
so she's already setting that up
and of course if you know needless to
say if you're if you're actually worried
about
truth and justice and all that kind of
stuff
it doesn't make any sense if you leave
aside the blatant jury intimidation jury
tampering she's doing here
like she she left it's not even that
she's given a press conference in dc
that'd be bad enough she went to the
community she went to the city where
this trial is happening
she went to the community where these
jurors live
and said if you don't give us a guilty
verdict if you don't in fact
conjure up a charge that doesn't exist
and convict them on that
um then we're going to be more
confrontational quote unquote wink wink
wink
but
if
even like leaving aside all the many
crimes she committed there um
obviously it doesn't make any sense
if you actually care about truth and
justice to be protesting
ahead of the jury verdict he was charged
we he had a trial that's what we do in
this country
and now the jury is going to weigh the
evidence and come to a determination
that's the way it's supposed to work
you know to demand a certain verdict
doesn't make any sense
if you care about truth and justice
which obviously they don't
and this is why we know look we've
closing arguments today
but the case has been presented right so
we can we can say now officially if
you've been following this the trial as
i have
that we have seen the state present its
whole case
and um i was not convinced by the
state's case all the whole way but i you
know i i at least
i'm the one preaching we have to let the
trial play out so i tried to allow that
to happen
thinking maybe i didn't think it was
going to happen but maybe they'll
somewhere
along the line they'll come up with with
with compelling evidence they never did
and so now we can say
after the trial has already happened
we've seen the state present its case
it doesn't really have a case
if the jury is making this decision
based on the evidence they would acquit
on all charges
not because they think derek chovin is a
great guy not because they want him to
be back on the police force
not even because they you know they
they're they're categorically rejecting
the idea that he murdered george floyd
but just because there's
just bundles of reasonable doubt here
reasonable doubt all over the place
through every facet
it is at least i think we can say this
like being as conservative
as we can it is at least
reasonably
plausible even now after seeing the
state's evidence
that george floyd died of a drug
overdose and nothing chauvin did caused
it
that that remain even now that remains a
reasonable possibility
which means he should be acquitted but
um i just don't see that happening
because these jurors think about the
situation they're in i first of all
i i i
if it were me
there's no way i would allow myself to
be on that jury
like i would say whatever i had to be to
say to not be on it
but the situation there now is um
this is happening in their community
this is where they live
and probably they're screwed no matter
what because like like we said like i
said they
choven isn't charged with first-degree
murder and that's what these morons in
the street want
and because they're morons or in the
case of maxine waters dishonest scumbags
and also a [ __ ]
they're going to blame the jury for the
fact that he's not convicted of
first-degree murder no matter what
happens
but if they were to acquit on all
charges here's what they know is going
to happen
their lives are ruined
and they may be killed for it
because their identities are going to
leak that's going to happen really
quickly
at a minimum they have to leave
basically enter witness protection
in effect
um
but this follows them for the rest of
their lives
they have to live the rest of their
lives looking over their shoulder
to come back with acquittal in a
situation like that
would require i mean immense
it would be one of the
greatest examples of moral courage i
think that we've seen in modern times
really
just to sim to to follow the evidence
and do your job knowing knowing what's
going to happen because of it
most people don't have that kind of
moral courage
i don't know if i have it like i said
i'd be trying to get off the jury
i got a family i gotta i gotta look out
for
now by the way um hours after maxine
waters
said that we have to get more
confrontational there was a drive-by
shooting against the national guard in
the city
hours later
so
i mean
do we know that they did that because
what maxine water said no
but they certainly are following her
recommendation
they're getting more confrontational
how do you get more confrontational
burning down buildings well start
shooting at the cops i guess the blm
they've been they've been doing that
but do it more yeah
that's one way
remember
trump at january 6th that his uh his
speech to the crowd
he actually said the words
now you can speculate speculate all you
want about his intentions and everything
else but he did say the words
uh peaceful he said we have to go
whatever whatever the exact phrase was i
know for sure he said the word peaceful
we have to speak out peacefully yeah you
know about about this he said words to
that effect but he put the word peaceful
in there
so all you're left with is speculation
that yeah he said peacefully didn't
really mean it and he knew that the
people in the crowd would interpret it
that way
well notice with these democrats they're
not even
they're not even bothering to say
peaceful with a wink
they could say that and it would
actually make a difference
if maxine waters had flown in from dc
and said listen guys
we're really upset about this and so on
and so forth validating all their their
emotions
but we we have to be peaceful this is
not the way to go about this
she had said something simple like that
it would have made a difference
but she doesn't want peace
it is um
the omission of that word
it almost doesn't matter anything else
she says the fact that the the deafening
silence from democrats that they will
not come out and even say let's be
peaceful
all right let's move on to uh number two
chris cuomo
on cnn couple days ago he said that if
you're a white parent
your child might need to be killed in
order for the political changes that he
wants to happen uh let's let's listen to
that
because you want to make the problem
then
takes the onus
off the idea that you're wrong about
policing not needing to change
forget that police are trained to deal
with non-compliance with force that is
not lethal
hey comply or die yeah i mean
and you know what the answer is
you really do you don't like it i don't
like it scares me
shootings
gun laws access to weapons oh you i know
when they'll change
your kids start getting killed
white people's kids start getting killed
smoking that doobie that's actually
legal probably in your state now but
they don't know what it was and then the
kid runs it pop pop pop
was justified why'd you run
oh he had a baseball game tonight oh the
white kid oh big family that house over
there
those start piling up
what is going on with these police
oh
what maybe we shouldn't even have police
that kind of mania that kind of madness
that'll be you
that'll be the majority because it's
your people
really well because
white people's kids are getting killed
by the cops
or how many times i have to explain that
that is happening it's happening more
often
than are
black people's kids being killed by the
cops more often it's not just happening
it's happening more often
500 since 2020
a little over 500 white people killed by
the cops
i don't know what
the the the comparison he's making there
the kid runs away because he's trying to
get to a baseball game but who
what
what is that supposed to be analogous to
what what
is that supposed to be adam toledo the
the 13 year old kid
he ran because he was trying to get to a
baseball game
at 3 a.m
after he was just firing a gun at a car
that's why the cops came to with adam
toledo and the 21 year old gangbanger
that he was with
adam toledo just gotten a latin kings
tattoo you know he's in a gang
a gang by the way that's terrorizing the
city
um and
and they were firing a gun at a passing
car
you know
you could easily kill someone just for
the sake of it
the cops know that
they know they're not there for a kid
smoking a doobie
um
to use cuomo's boomer language
they know that they were not called to
the scene because uh someone complained
that there are some kids out out
out in the street smoking a joint
they're called the scene to gang to a
gang-infested area
because there's people firing guns at
passing cars
so that's what they know
and then they see someone they don't
know if he's they don't know his age in
that moment it doesn't make a difference
it's someone with a loaded gun
no matter your age you're just as
capable of firing a gun and killing
somebody
so they see someone
with a gun
that they know was just being used
and then he runs and he stops and he
turns around
and ditches the gun behind a fence so
that so so that the cops can't see him
do it
what no the implication from from idiots
like cuomo is that if if adam toledo was
white they wouldn't have shot
could they even tell his race it's 3 a.m
and they're out in
a dark back alley could they even tell
what his race was
are you suggesting
because what this was about for the cop
who fired the shot
um justifiably fired the shot
for him it was a matter of
self-preservation
confronting a suspect you don't know who
got a load got a gun that he was just
firing
um
dark alley
he's got nowhere to take cover he's
totally this cob is totally exposed
he knows this this person the suspect
has a gun he turns and now it's just
it's self-preservation do i want to go
home and see my family tonight or do i
want to die right now
do i want this
whoever this is this gangster who i
don't know who it is do i want them to
kill me do i want to be taken down by
this person that's that's the uh the
decision now
are you suggesting that
if he knew the kid the suspect didn't
know was a kid if he knew the suspect it
was white he'd be more willing to be
killed
you think that's going to factor into
his calculation he's going to say well
he's white uh you know i'll take one for
the team
it is so delusionally insane this this
claim
99.99 of police shootings
even the unjustified ones
it's about self-preservation for the
police they're trying to save their own
lives
there are cases where they
are a little too eager to do that
um
the uh the uh daniel shaver case
which again is one that
blm completely ignores even though it is
the worst police shooting ever caught on
video to my mind
it's certainly it's it's certainly up
there
blm ignores it because daniel shaver was
white but um the cops there did they
kill him they were all white people in
that hallway
when they shot daniel shaver like while
he was on his knees beg literally
begging for his life um they were all
white people was it racially motivated
no
did that cop
you know go to that hallway intent he
just felt like killing someone that day
probably not
this was self-preservation but he wasn't
willing to take any chance at all he'd
rather just kill this guy even if even
if there was like a point zero one
percent chance that the guy had a gun
hidden somewhere about to pull it out
he said i'd rather just kill him
doesn't make it okay that police officer
should have went to jail that was murder
but let's just let's be
reasonable thinking adults about what
motivates these kinds of things
most of the time when a cop even a cop
is being overly aggressive why is he
being overly aggressive
all it takes is a basic understanding of
human psychology
you know
self-preservation is is an overwhelming
overriding factor
it can go too far
in the case of adam toledo
self-preservation led to a tragic result
but it didn't go too far that was a he
made a reasonable choice
that i submit almost anyone else would
have made if they were in that alley
that night facing an unknown perp who
has a gun that he was just firing
all right um
let's see what else do we have here
i wanna okay we're gonna play i gotta
play this um
from the hilt says the mother of a
transgender boy in texas went viral this
week after making an emotional plea to
state lawmakers about a bill that would
make it illegal for parents to provide
gender affirming health care gender
affirming health care quotes around that
procedures for their children under the
bill parents aiding their transgender
children and receiving medical care
including puberty suppressant drugs
medical procedures and hormone
replacement therapy would be labeled
abusers and their actions would be
considered a felony if the child is
under the age of 18. great law
but amber briggle um who's the
mother of a quote unquote trans boy
didn't like it she spoke out during the
legislative session and this went uh
this went viral a lot of you you go girl
type of type of responses from the left
um let's let's listen to what she had to
say
good afternoon my name is amber brigel
and i am terrified to be here today
i'm terrified because i'm the parent of
a transgender child and i'm afraid that
by speaking here today my words will be
used against me
should sb 1646 or sb1311 pass
and my sweet son whom i love more than
life itself
will be taken from me
but here i am
i want you to know how hard it is for me
to be here today
not only am i terrified for the future
of my family but i'm a small business
owner with two children at home who are
still going to public school 100 online
i have a million better things to do
than be here today
like rebuilding my business and
supervising my children's online
learning and repairing the damage that
occurred to my home when the electric
grid failed
but this committee and the bill's
authors somehow deems my son's private
medical care more important than covet
relief for women-owned small businesses
or making public schools safer or fixing
ercot okay i want to stop it there for
just one second
um she has about three and a half
minutes we're not gonna play the whole
thing i'll have some mercy on you but
she has about three and a half minutes
to
make her point give her a little speech
now we're almost a half of the way into
it
um
over a third of the way into it
and
you notice what
like a minute 15 seconds out of three
minutes
i me
my
this is all about her
she spent the first third at least
talking about herself
that's that should tell you something
for these parents it it's it's about
them
okay that's that's
this is not a coincidence
this is almost always the case when you
listen to parents of quote-unquote trans
children
and you hear them make their case it
it's it's like
mostly them and then they'll throw in
and we'll get to this in a second
and then they'll throw in their concerns
for their child
but the justification for how they're
treating their child and and and the
long-term effects on their child and
the well-being of their child that's
really an afterthought
it's it's mostly about them
as far as her child goes let's listen to
what she has to say
son was four years old he asked me if
scientists could turn him into a boy
i didn't understand then that he was
trans
i only knew that he wasn't like most
girls his age and that something inside
him was hurting
like many of you i thought he was asking
for surgery and i freaked out
but after doing research i came to
understand that gender affirmation
surgery isn't done on minors and that
there is a whole array of medical
options available for transgender youth
including hormone blockers which are 100
reversible are not new and are
clinically proven to save the lives of
the trans children taking them okay
uh none of that is true by the way it's
all completely false
now it's it may be true that in most
cases
the
surgical mutilation is is going to
happen
after they turn 18
but but the conditioning and the
brainwashing leading to that happens
when they're young
so the fact that you're waiting until
they turn 18 actually do this thing that
you've conditioned them for and
brainwashed them into for all these
years you know that that to me doesn't
make me feel any better at all
um
but what you're doing before that is
drugging them
chemical castration before you get to
the physical surgical castration again
it doesn't make me feel much better
about it doesn't make it any better
what she said about is a 100 percent
totally
totally reversible
that is bs
she she does not no
nobody actually really knows the full
long-term effects of this
because we've never done it on anything
approaching this scale ever before in
history this is a new thing
this generation of children they are the
guinea pig generation we don't actually
know
before this you have scattered cases
here and there but but but this
to this extent we have not had a sample
size put it this way we haven't had a
sample size big enough
to really know yet what the long-term
effects are
so all of these children with the rever
totally reversible and safe uh
puberty blockers
what
impact is that going to have on them 20
years from now 30 years from now
you don't really know
you don't
you just
hope that it works out
and even if it doesn't you
your your child's long-term physical
health and even short-term physical
health
is um
a side issue that's not that's not the
primary thing for you
and then she says uh when my child was
four years old he came to me and said
can scientists turn me into a girl or no
it was a girl who's a who's a boy now
right
identifying as a boy
let me rephrase it's a girl whose mother
has identified her as a boy okay
so she says that when her
daughter
was four she said can scientists turn me
into a boy
this is
a really easy thing to handle as a as a
parent
it's not even a difficult situation it's
not
okay
when your four-year-old says something
like that very easy
i don't even want to hear i i i it's it
it goes too far for me when i hear
conservatives sometimes say well
at least we have to admit this is a
difficult situation for parents no it's
not
especially not at that age
now you've got a 16 year old who out of
nowhere and i've heard of cases like
this
16 year old out of nowhere comes home
one day and says i want to change
genders that's difficult
of course the response from the parent
you could you can never go along with it
but it's not a simple thing to solve and
it's going to take therapy it's good
it's just that that is is difficult
that's painful as a parent
for a four-year-old though not hard i
don't want to hear that it's hard it's
so hard i didn't know what to do he's
four she's four
you know what you say when when the
daughter says can scientists change me
into a boy uh no they can't
you're a girl and that's that's a
wonderful thing
oh but i i think i'm a boy
it's okay you're a girl it's okay go run
along and play
that's it that's all you have to do it
is it is really that simple and that
easy
uh unless
you know
unless as a parent you were waiting for
something like that or maybe you planted
those seeds in your child's head
because this is munchausen syndrome by
proxy and you are planting this gender
dysphoria in the child's head
for your own purposes
because you want to parade your kid
around like a prop
and show the world how enlightened you
are as parents
but if you actually are concerned just
for any parent
whatever a four-year-old say
four-year-olds are actually really easy
to deal with
they are
they're these are these are simple
innocent little kids they're easy to
deal with
all right let's um okay we're gonna move
on to reading the youtube comments
this one from is from fern diaz says
thank you for calling out the stupidity
behind the term la tinx i along with
every single friend of mine who are
latino or latina think it's idiotic
and would never use it and would not
want anyone to use it to describe us
yeah i i have honestly yet to hear it
i've brought this up several times
you know on the internet and i've you
know i've just
because i'm curious
is there any latino person who actually
likes this term and uses it
i've yet to meet a single one
um but
you wouldn't expect
that because not only is it is it is it
ridiculous but it also it doesn't make
in in it doesn't make any sense spanish
language it doesn't la tinx doesn't mean
it doesn't make any sense
and it is such a gendered language that
to randomly
you know degender this one term again
makes no sense
um
audrey says honestly i support matt's
decision to look atrocious once every
week with that shirt takes guts god's
speed brother
you know i'm going to take that as a
compliment because you're saying i only
look at trolls just once a week
there are those who would say it's more
often than that
um
jared powell says your opening on this
was on this was so true but legitimately
depressing to listen to the kid was 13
and never really had a chance i you know
i agree with you
i mean yeah of course it's a terrible
thing it's depressing it's tragic
but when you say the kid never had a
chance i
i really i agree with you there too
that's why a 13 year i don't i don't
blame the 13 year old kid he's 13.
right and you take
take me take you take any one
and you put them in the environment that
this kid was in
take the father out of the picture
uh you know neglect at home
falls in with the wrong crowd parents
don't care about it or just aren't on
the scene like all of that together all
the things we talked about on friday
you take any kid
and throw him into that situation
um
they could be the one in that back alley
by the fence holding the gun
so yeah that's why you know i don't
blame the kid at the 13 is so young
you know
and your your ability that's one of the
points i always come back to with the
gender thing
these kids are so young and their
ability to
to
evaluate
risk and reward and to make
and to make mature long-term decisions
and all that kind of stuff discernment i
mean their ability to do any of that
is shall we say very very underdeveloped
is why for me it goes back to the
parents i don't blame the kid i blame
the parents
the kid you can't expect them to know
better given the circumstances
the adults around him you do expect them
to know better
and to do a better job of raising their
kids
and so that's where i put the blame
not on the cop not on the kid all the
parents
finally this is from hank who has
apparently written a poem about my polka
dot shirt that i that you go through all
that effort i have to read it on the
show
um
here it is
oh how the interstices of many a white
dot defy darkness with their promise of
light and ardor that through the fabric
matt's tender heart is not cancelled by
virtue of this his knight's armor
this majestic men's blouse seamed with
gold
cast wide its net of fashion's statement
that this his soul so pure so bold
impresses the oppression of his critics
abatement
and so to you sir i bid god's speed on
your departure from your shirts so
flanneled
and pray indeed that you may consider my
own need that this poem be heralded and
summarily canceled
well done
i really brought tear to my eye it
actually did you can't see it i only
cried invisible tears
because i'm a man but uh it is i'm
crying on the inside beautiful
that my you know what this so this is
not that my polka dot shirt
could bring this kind of beauty into the
world
that's a lesson for all of us i think
isn't it
uh well done well done good sir
some people might be surprised to learn
this but i actually am uh i i enjoy
cooking and i think i'm a pretty i'm a
pretty darn good cook if i if i do say
so myself
um at least that's what my wife will
will will tell me i think because she
likes it when i cook so she doesn't have
to so she flatters me but one thing
about cooking is that you get a lot of
appliances in the kitchen they take up a
lot of space and that's why it's great
to get an appliance that kind of can
cover a lot of the other bases that you
use other appliances for chef emerald
agassi's power air fryer 360 is what you
got to check out it's award winning for
a reason this is so much more than an
air fryer it's an air fryer rotisserie
toaster broiler pizza oven and more all
in one so you get rid of all that other
stuff all you need is this do you love
fried foods but hate the guilt well
emeralds air fryer 360 cooks with hot
air not oil so you can cook healthier
for with up to 70 fewer calories from
fat plus it's faster than traditional
appliances so how they do it their 360
degree quick cook turbo heat technology
cooks food with a whirlwind of
superheated air to get that great crispy
fried taste but you're not getting all
the oils and everything in it which
means that it's not only healthier but
for me more important healthy is that it
is the taste
and i don't care about health i care
about taste and it tastes a lot better
as well you got to try this yourself
emeralds air fryer 360 makes an amazing
mother's day gift right now they have an
exclusive offer just for the matt wall
show listeners it's uh if you go to try
emeraldair.com and use promo code wall
she'll receive 10 off plus free shipping
now's the time to get that gift for
mother's day so try to head to head now
to try emerald air it's
t-r-y-e-n-e-r-i-l-air.com use our promo
code walsh one last time try
emeraldair.com
and use promo code walsh
well it's almost time for another
episode of candace this week's special
guest is dana white president of the
ultimate fighting championship which is
the largest mixed martial arts
organization in the world and you
probably already know dana white is but
i explained it if you needed it the the
show streams on fridays at 9 pm eastern
8 pm central only on dailywire.com and
you can get 25 off a new membership with
code candace also get the audio podcast
canvas as well on apple spotify or
wherever you listen to your podcast
if you need some candid subways in your
podcast feed make sure to go there leave
the five star review if you like what
you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we're going to cancel slates and
the the reason may seem counterintuitive
at first well there's nothing
counterintuitive about canceling slate
in general you know they could be
canceled every day in principle simply
for existing but the specific thing
that's causing the cancel hammer to come
down on them today is this article
published on saturday with the title
it's about time for us to stop wearing
masks outside and then it says briefly
passing someone on the sidewalk just
isn't risky
the article goes on to make the simple
case already summarized that wearing
masks outdoors is effectively pointless
you almost certainly aren't going to
spread covet or contract it by walking
past someone on a sidewalk the piece
concludes with this paragraph
while i'm not super interested in
breaking my city's social norms
especially while our cases are still
high our collective agreement to mask up
obsessively outdoors comes at a cost
masking can be exhausting it can it
makes recreation really annoying
especially as the weather warms it makes
it difficult to escape even temporarily
from the pandemic it deprives us of
seeing one another smiles i'm aware that
these are also arguments deployed by
those who decry all masking even indoors
but the point is that masking shouldn't
be about signaling what side you're on
it should be about using a tool in
response to a risk
being overly vigilant about masks when
they are not important makes it more
difficult to keep wearing them when they
are also i fear that it is making us
look a little ridiculous
well the last point is wrong i mean it
doesn't make you look a little
ridiculous
also notice how this this is a
presumably a left-wing writer and slate
saying
i don't want to break
my town's social norms
oh how the cultural radicals have fallen
i don't want to break
isn't that your whole thing in slate
breaking social norms
now why why am i canceling slate for
making an argument that's correct and
which i myself have been making for
months on end
because it's too late
the left-wing media has been
fear-mongering for too long and as a
result many people in this country have
become paranoid lunatics and there may
be no rescuing them now
the time for sanity was months ago
now this sane and reasonable position
which is also scientifically
unassailable was met with anger by
slate's own readers
just listen to some of the comments
under this article when they posted it
to twitter
i'll read a few
we don't wear them to only protect
ourselves we wear them to help protect
others what is wrong with you
someone else says wearing my mask
outside makes me feel safer it also
helps to reduce the amount of pollen i'm
breathing in as well i felt so much
better this spring
someone else says actually i like
wearing my mask when i go for walks and
we'll be sad to see them go i don't have
to eat to eat eat dust or exhaust from
traffic having 100 sunblock uh need no
moisturizer or lipstick and see people
learning to look into each other's
windows of the soul
someone else says she can say what she
wants pre masks when walking behind
someone who was smoking and they exhaled
you got waft of smoke in your face if
the wind was right covet is no different
only you can't see it if you're walking
behind someone you could be breathing
their exhalation
someone else is the writer a doctor i
appreciate the sighting of studies but
one more random person's opinion on how
to wear masks is unhelpful why even
publish this we have enough issues with
masking mask wearing generally
regardless of whether this opinion has
any validity
and then here's my favorite
more click bait bs must be losing
readers
only they spelled losing l-o-o-s-n
s-i-n-g so it's losing readers
um yeah click bait just saying hey guys
uh we probably don't have to wear masks
outside that's click bait look at this
the point is they see that as not just
wrong but like outlandish
it is outlandishly wrong
that you should wear a mask outside
so outlandish that if you say it the
only reason you could possibly be saying
it is just for clickbait
see it's almost terrifying to peer even
briefly into the minds of these
disturbed and pitiful people
their brains have been broken
they need the mask as a security blanket
to simply walk outside their house in
some cases they're admitting that that's
the case at this point a person wearing
a mask outside should be treated with
the same respect
as a grown man clutching his teddy bear
while he walks down the street it's
exactly the same sort of thing
and to be clear we should not have any
respect for the grown man with the teddy
bear
like our response to that should be the
same imagine walking you see a grown man
with his teddy bear and a pacifier in
his mouth walking down the street
now of course you know i this doesn't
really work because these days we
probably would be told that we have to
have respect for that person's lifestyle
choices
but in saner times you would look at
that and say what the hell this guy's
crazy it's the same thing
speaking of men who clutch teddy bears a
guy named nick uh nudsen
a somehow his name is just perfect i
don't know why huffpo writer and
democrat activist posted his uh his
outdoor mask selfie to twitter along
with this caption
he says retweet if you're partially or
fully vaccinated but you're still
wearing a mask to help protect your
community hashtag wear a mask post a
photo in the reply
nick is vaccinated
and wearing his mask outside
many people on the replies are in his
boat and proud of it one woman who
apparently works for disney
posted a picture of herself out in
public in an astronaut helmet
not meant to be a joke
and it isn't a joke it's mental illness
this is mental illness that's been
fostered instilled into the minds of the
public by guys like dr fauci
and fauci's not letting up anytime soon
here he is on meet the press yesterday
recommending that people still wear
masks while vaccinated let's listen to
that
why does a vaccinated person have to
wear a mask
okay this is something that as we get
more information it's going to be
pulling back that you won't have to but
currently the reason is
that when you get vaccinated you are
clearly diminishing dramatically your
risk of getting infected that's one of
the things we've got to make sure
everybody understands you dramatically
diminish it however what happens is that
you might get infected and get
absolutely no symptoms not know you're
infected and then inadvertently go into
a situation with vulnerable people and
if you don't have a mask you might
inadvertently
infect them now there's a small risk of
that but it's there the other thing is
that there may be variants that are
circulating we know new york area has
their own variant a 526 there's a south
african variant fortunately for us chuck
the 117 variant that is dominant in
europe and in uk is also now dominant in
the united states thank goodness the
vaccine works very well against that
variant
now just so you know
the cdc says that point zero zero eight
percent of vaccinated people have had
breakthrough cases where they still get
covered so he talks about a small risk
okay
let's be clear about how small point
zero zero eight percent that's not
that's not much higher than your chance
of getting struck by lightning it's much
smaller much smaller than your chance of
dying in a car accident
there are a million risks out there
which pose a greater threat
than point zero zero eight percent
if we're supposed to mask even with
8.008 risk
then we really shouldn't be going
anywhere or doing anything
we shouldn't walk down the steps without
a helmet on maybe the astronaut helmet
or eat a meal without chopping it into
small bits first to prevent choking
or sit in a bathtub without a life
jacket
you know
on this risk assessment philosophy
you shouldn't be doing anything
0.08 risk is is the kind of risk that
healthy insane people ignore
yes you just ignore it
when someone tells you there's a 0.08
chance of such-and-such happening you
just okay go about your day
because the only other option is
paralyzation
if you have to respond to a risk like
that at all then you can't live your
life
the only other option is to basically
give up on living a normal human life
all in the hopes of preserving the very
life that you've effectively forfeited
these are the kinds of calculations that
millions of americans have lost the
ability to make this is the point
we all used to make them intuitively
you know there have always been areas
where our caution exceeded what is
statistically justified like for example
parents
worry that their kids are going to be
kidnapped by a stranger in a van or
something something that almost never
happens in real life
but most parents and that's been the
case for a while you know are more
worried about that and take more
precautions against it
than is statistically justified but for
the most part
most of us carried on living our lives
basically free of crippling paranoia but
that's not the case anymore for many
people cobid was the first time that
they seriously faced their own mortality
and that
you know startling confrontation coupled
with the sustained fear mongering and
panic porn from the media caused a sort
of psychotic break for a lot of people
for most people the risk posed by covid
was never lethal
or even especially severe for most
people
but the combination of psychological
factors noted above made it so made it
so that you know lots of these people
could not
process the situation that they found
themselves in
we all have an internal risk calculator
that's working all the time and for a
lot of people it broke
next you know they're walking alone in
the woods with two masks and a visor
publications like slate and other
left-wing media outlets could have
helped prevent this early on by simply
being reasonable and honest
but the media are the ones who push the
idea early on that there's no difference
between 100 risk and point zero zero one
percent risk
you know any risk is too much
that's why you weren't allowed to point
out that there's no reason to wear a
mask outside or that asymptomatic
transmission really probably isn't a
huge concern yes it can happen anytime
you bring this up people always say
what do you mean it can happen
i mean maybe it can but it's it's
there's no reason to think that it's
likely
you weren't allowed to say that
you also weren't allowed to say that hey
you know washing your hands is great and
all but you're probably not going to get
coveted from touching a surface that a
guy with covet touched three hours ago
like you don't need to use
a hand sanitizer every time you touch
something
weren't allowed to say that all of these
true and reasonable things were shouted
down in some in some cases censored by
big tech
the marching orders for an entire year
were that no amount of coveted risk is
acceptable none
and this of course was always insane and
unworkable but it's the dynamic that
outlets like slate helped to create
now some of them may want to pull back
perhaps because some of the people
you know working in these outlets who
push the panic porn really are just sick
of living like this
but it's too late
in fact just a couple of months ago
slate itself published an article
recommending
double masking
outside
now they want to retreat back into a
semblance of sanity i wish that were
possible for a lot of people it's not
they've gone insane
and oftentimes that trip is a one-way
ticket
and that's why slate and all other
coveted fear peddlers are once again
completely and totally
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens production
manager pavel vadosky the show is edited
by sasha tolmachov our audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair makeup is done by
nikka geneva and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. maxine
waters calls for more leftist street
violence the public health regime
becomes permanent and anglo-saxons get
canceled check it out on the michael
knowles show